ce moment c'est un jeune homme de 18 ans
et un jour et déjà médaillé d'or sans
prénom t descendant famille renner il
faisait ses débuts en championnat
d'europe de gedo un colosse de 2 m 0,4
et 130 kg portrait nathanaël de
rincquesen et aaron en visite ce matin à
l'aéroport de roissy david douillet et
teddy riner était inséparable photos
autographes
riner est présenté comme le futur
douillet du judo français le plus drôle
c'est que ce n'est peut-être pas un
hasard vocation aux coïncidences cette
photo de david été dit a été prise il ya
dix ans la lutte est petit et l'a vu il
a vu des champions mon époque quoi et ça
lui a donné envie et ça fait plaisir
c'est quelque part
de susciter des vocations ce top il
venait d'avoir 18 ans ce week-end teddy
riner a fêté son anniversaire à sa
manière ses adversaires ont à peine eu
le temps de constater qu'il était fort
comme un homme thédié devenu champion
d'europe
un gabarit basketteurs un physique de
boxeur
lorsqu'il est arrivé à l'insep plusieurs
sports ont essayé de débaucher les dix
est un touche à tout naturellement doué
pour le sport c'est la conséquence d'une
hyper activité que sa mère agirait comme
elle a pu ma mère le mercredi est muté à
l'aquaboulevard en faisant judo tennis
squash cole jazz moderne piscine
histoire d'être bien fatigué à la fin de
la journée
mais le mariage du cheveu du foot de
mètres 0 430 kg teddy riner esquisse à
peine à vos bébés plus jeune champion
d'europe de l'histoire
champion du monde junior dans sa
catégorie teddy décrochent les titres
avec une facilité déconcertante même
pour ses entraîneurs qui lui prédisent
un avenir torts et forcément il ya une
carrière devant lui il ya dix ans de
haut niveau voit pas le on va pas le
cramer tout de suite c'est à dire que là
aujourd'hui on est quand même dans une
période de construction de formation
avec telly et on ira ce matin teddy
n'avait d'yeux que pour sa photo dans le
journal l'équipe jeux olympiques
championnats du monde ça lui donne des
idées